>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> On behalf of the
Library of Congress welcome
to the 2010 national book festival.
I'm Joe Yonan, the food and travel
editor from the Washington Post.
And thank you for celebrating
the joy of reading today.
Before we start, for those of you
who didn't hear my caveats earlier,
I just want to make sure you know
that the presentations are being
filmed for the Library of Congress,
for the website and
for their archives.
Be mindful of that.
Don't sit in front of camera
risers to block the cameras,
which I think is that right there.
And please, please take your
cell phones, take the on button,
turn it to the off button.
That would be great.
I have the distinct
pleasure of introducing
to you Lidia Matticchio Bastianich.
[ Clapping ]
>> I could probably stop there, but
I really like to talk about Lidia.
So I'm going to say
a little bit more.
First of all, she is one of
those few cooking personalities
that needs to go by only one name.
I always love that.
And she really at this point
has become, I would say,
America's favorite
Italian cooking teacher.
[ Clapping ]
-
>> She's everybody's mother.
She's everybody's grandmother.
She tells you to watch
closely as you stir the pot.
She tells you to make sure you
heavily salt that pasta water.
She tells you to cook the
pasta until it's just al dente.
Save a little bit of the
water for the pasta sauce.
But while she's telling
you all this,
you don't feel talked
down to at all.
You feel included.
You feel welcome at Lidia's table.
And you can practically smell
and practically taste every
little thing that she's cooking.
Her accomplishments are too numerous
for me to list here honestly.
I want Lidia to have some time
to talk, but she's the owner
of several acclaimed restaurants,
starting with Lidia
in New York City.
She's the author of many spectacular
cookbooks, Lu Cucina di Lidia,
Lidia's Family Table, Lidia's
Italian Table, Lidia's Italy,
Lidia's Cooks From
the Heart of Italy.
And all of them showcase
the glorious variety,
depth and beauty of Italian cooking.
Her many public television shows
and appearances bring the viewers
not just into her own kitchen,
but into the kitchens of
her favorite Italian cooks.
And make sure -- I can speak
from personal experience,
because I was just there recently.
Make sure that the next time you go
to New York, make sure that you stop
by one of her newest
ventures with Mario Batali
and her son Joe Bastianich,
the huge temple glorious,
hilarious crowded amusement
park like temple
to Italian cooking that is Italy.
Lidia has also been honored by the
government of Italy, I have to say,
for being such a wonderful
embassador
of Italian cooking in America.
I was honored to be at that
presentation a few months ago.
She's a guru of Italian
cooking in America.
So, ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome
to the stage Lidia Bastianich.
[ Clapping ]
>> Thank you.
Wow. Bonjourno.
[inaudible].
It's a pleasure being here.
I really enjoy, I do, the
restaurants and the books,
but I truly enjoy meeting
you, because I know
that on the other side
of the screen or all
of my books there is you out there.
And you ultimately connect.
And I'll go back maybe
to the whole history,
but when I did my first book --
and my first book is Lu Cucina
di Lidia -- it was in 1990.
And I was then a chef of Lidia.
The first restaurant I opened was
in '71, for Lidia opened in '81.
And I was, you know, cooking
the food of my region.
Now, in '71 when I
began cooking, the food,
that was Italian American food.
And by all means, delicious food,
but it was not the food that I ate
at home or that was cooked in Italy.
And I dedicated a whole
book to that,
to that Lidia's Italian-American
Kitchen,
this valiant kitchen of adaptation.
But when I opened for
Lidia, I cooked the food
of Friuli Venezia Giulia.
And if you are looking at Italy,
in the right-hand corner,
Italy has 20 regions.
In the right hand corner is Friuli
Venezia Giulia, right under Austria.
Now it's next to Slovenia.
So the food is almost
middle European.
So I cook European.
I cook with sauerkraut.
I make goulash.
I make balanchine.
So here I was cooking this
kind of really regional food.
And do I that because
I had this great plan?
No. Because it was what I knew.
I came here when I was 12.
That's what we cooked at
home when I was growing up.
That's what we continue to cook when
we came to America as immigrants.
So as I got really into
cooking or whatever, I said,
I'm going to took Italian, but
I'm going to cook what I know.
And certainly the press followed,
because maybe it was the first look
into not a homogenized
Italian cuisine,
but a regional Italian cuisine.
And, you know, those
of you that travel,
and certainly by now
it's quite evident,
how really different
all the regions are.
You know, Italy's smaller
than California.
And yet the diversity that lies
within its region as far as food,
as far as product is
just tremendous.
I keep on going back.
I mean, I'm here since 1958.
So it's 50 years.
So I need to go back.
I need to nurture myself
and continuously I explore
and find new things in
this little country.
So in 1990 when I opened for Lidia
and all the press and everything,
of course, amongst the press
there was a gentleman JJ Goode.
He wrote -- he was a
writer for Gourmet Magazine.
And he said, "Lidia, you
need to write a cookbook."
And so I said, "but
I'm not a writer.
I'm a chef."
And at that I am a chef
of home cooking in a way.
I always stuck to that.
Even when I went to culinary
school, I felt most comfortable,
and I think you all
relate exactly to that.
How do you make it at home?
How does it happen?
And I think that's some
of the best food anyway.
So he asked me, "how
about writing a book?"
And I said, "Well, maybe
we can collaborate."
And we did.
And he interviewed me.
And the book is really about that
region, because I said, "I can't."
I thought, I said, "okay.
So what am I going to write about?
Am I going do write about
what I do as a chef?"
I says, no.
I have to tell them my story,
the food, where it comes from.
And so began my philosophy
of how do I write for you
so that I can connect so that you
really can transport my flavors
into your kitchen.
And the book is still being printed,
was the book actually my biography
in short, and the food
of Friuli Vanezia Giulia,
that region up there.
From then on I went on two books.
Of course, I addressed the
Italian American cuisine.
I addressed the family table,
because I think the responses
that I got, especially from
TV, is this connection.
Everybody connects to the table
or the missing of that connection.
So the feeling, what a table --
I think that a table full of food
with family and friends is magical.
It's a place that you
can really connect.
Maybe not enough of it.
And we should really
build that ever more.
And one would say, oh, the cooking.
No. Simple food, a nice salad,
maybe some pasta, whatever,
will bring people together.
But let me tell you maybe why,
because I'm interested in food,
but I'm interested in
all aspects of food.
I'm interested in the
story, the history,
anthropology, the sociology,
whatever.
You know, it intrigues me.
So when you're at the table, now,
the one thing that we all must do,
we must eat in order to live.
You must eat to survive.
When you're eating,
you're taking in.
Your defenses are down.
You need that food so
that you stay alive.
So there's no argument there.
So when you're at the table, when
we're at the table, we are relaxed.
Our defenses are down, and
we are taking in nourishment.
It's the perfect place to talk.
Why do we have business
lunches or dinners?
Why do we do proposals, why do we
do special events around the table?
Because it is a special place
that we find that we can connect
with each other better,
because our defenses are down.
So just this little -- you know,
that table is really, really --
especially for young people and for
teenagers, if you take a teenager
and you say, okay, let's go
upstairs in the room and let's talks
about drugs, it's on
the defensive already.
But at the table as you're talking,
they're taking all of that in.
So The Family Table was a book
that I addressed specifically
because of this, how do
you cook for families
and together and, also, cooking big.
You know, there's a lot of
work in members of the family,
both members at some time, how
do you make, if you're going
to make a pot of sauce,
how do you make it larger?
Save it and then that sauce
can be turned into the meal
for the whole week almost.
The same with soup, making a base.
So that book addressed that.
And then I went back to Italy
and Lidia's Italy and Lidia Cooks
from the Heart of Italy, which
is my latest book in the series
that you're watching, is
about the 20 regions of Italy.
Lidia Cooks from the Heart of
Italy, which is the latest,
is maybe the ten less known regions.
And I think it's fantastic.
And I get a lot of comments from
readers and from guests that come
to my restaurant about how
they relate to this book,
the regions of Italy they didn't
know or the regions of Italy
that their ancestors came
from Calavia, Basilicata,
Abruzzo, Molise, all of these.
This is the last book.
Now you say, okay, this is the
story of how you got into books,
but how did you get in television?
But let's just go back to the
restaurant business as a whole.
So I was very young and in
'71 opened my first restaurant
with my husband.
I was not a chef.
I was 23 then.
We hired a chef.
I became his pseu chef
for ten years.
And that's where I really
got my kind of knowledge
of commercial cooking, but I
always retained my personal
of the family cooking.
The children were born.
Joe was born, Tonya was born
in the restaurant itself.
And they would come.
My mother, she's still
-- those of you
who watch television still see her.
She's 90. She lives with me
and she's still involved.
So this sense of unity and maybe
family, you know, one would, say,
oh, my goodness, you
know, that's so hard.
For me it was -- it's a necessity.
It is the Italian way of life.
And we continued, but
it was a blessing,
because I could continue to work.
And my mother would watch the
children at night while I worked.
So as the kids grew up, you know,
always the thing is the restaurant
is kind of a fun place to be.
You know, everybody's
always having fun.
Everybody is always having a drink.
So I said to my son and my
daughter when she came, I said, no,
this is not what you want to do.
We came as immigrants to America.
You're going to get an education.
This is the land of opportunity.
And then you can really do
whatever you like and move on
and we'll be very proud of you.
So my son went on to Wall Street,
analyst, college, whatever.
My daughter went on, art
history, PhD from Oxnard.
Ultimately they both worked with me.
But, you know, I think -- and
it's a very hard challenge,
I mean, when you're a parent.
And if you're young, you're sort of
left steering them or mentoring them
to go and build their life.
When they come back then
as adults, as partners,
it's a different challenge.
But I love every minute.
I still do.
And if I am capable of doing
what I have, it's because of them
and so many other really competent
individuals that I have on my team.
My son got into the business,
of course, in the restaurants.
And we are partners
with Mario Batali.
So all the restaurants we own
with Mario Batali together.
And in Italy we were just
talking, that's a partnership
between the three of us and
also some Italian counterparts.
And my daughter, on the other hand,
when she came back to the states,
she got married, to have
children, to be close to home,
I sort of pulled her in,
help me do the research,
help me with the books.
So she takes care of a lot of
the books and the television
and all of those research items.
So the television.
How did I get into television?
Well, at this other restaurant
for Lidia, as I said, you know,
all the [inaudible] would come
then for Lidia opening in 1981.
James Beard, Julia Child.
And then all the journalists
would come.
And that's when Julia Child
approached me and said, Lidia --
"Lidia [in accent] would
you do a show with me?"
Well, we did two shows in
the Master Chef series.
And I guess the rest is what really
what explains how ultimately I got
into television.
The producer asked me, "Lidia,
the shows were really good.
Would you consider?"
And I thought about it.
And, of course, you
know, I'm a communicator.
I love -- and, you know,
just I think, you know,
what I do is something very basic.
I didn't plan it this way.
I love it, but to have
the reaction from you
like that just drives me even more.
You know, I need to do more.
And I just love it.
I mean, you're getting
energy from me.
I get all that energy back.
And I'm doing what I'm doing
because of all of that energy.
I just wanted to share with
you that it's a two way street.
I wanted to share with you.
And so I said, yes,
but I had two requests.
I said if I could tape the show
in my house and if I could be
on public television, because I felt
that public television was
the platform [clapping] --
was the platform for
what I had to say.
I'm happy to say that I'm
still in public television
and I'm still filming in my home.
So the set that you
see, that's my home.
And I get up there every morning.
Actually, I left there this morning.
Grandma was still sleeping.
There's no more kids now.
So she was still resting.
But I have begun yesterday
the filming of my new series.
So they come in.
And, actually, they take
over my whole house.
And it's four cameras
and all the controls.
It's great.
And that's going to be for the next
series that's coming out next year,
which is Lidia's Italy in America.
And it's about the Italian culture,
the immigrants way back
historical and, of course,
ultimately all culminating
with recipes as examples.
And I'll be going around
the United States.
I mean, I have done tons
of research, you know,
how important the different ports,
what the Italians bring with them,
I mean, the whole phenomena
of broccoli rabe [audible].
Fifth generation immigrants
from Sicily, they came,
and they were missing
that bitter green.
On the trip back brought the seeds,
because broccoli rabe
in Italy grows wild.
And they brought back
the seeds, planted it.
And ultimately the story,
they sell millions of pounds
of broccoli de rabe,
America really loves.
The same with the artichokes.
The artichokes and those -- the
big farms out there are still ran
by fourth, fifth generations
of Italians.
So I go and explore
all of these stories.
And I will be bringing them to you.
That's next year in a book.
But I do have a new project
that I want to share with you.
And that is -- which
I'm very proud of.
And that is that I have a children's
book coming out on October 12th.
[clapping] And then I'll let
you ask all the questions,
because I'm just touching things
to stimulate you in a way to see
if you have any questions.
The book is Nonna, Tell Me a Story.
And it is the story
of a Christmas tree.
It's a Christmas story.
And with my grandkids,
they all come over and,
you know, we sort of pile in bed.
And the question is always,
Nonna, tell me a story
when you were a little girl.
Now, I grew up in a setting, I tell
everybody, with my grandmother.
In the country we had all
the courtyard animals,
goats, pigs, donkeys.
We had it all, all the garden.
But the Christmas was
quite different
and organic than what is done here.
And what we did is that my
grandfather would go out.
And he wouldn't take the top of
the whole tree, ruin a whole tree.
That wasn't thought of.
Juniper bush or a bush
that was that high,
he would chop that off, bring it in.
And we would decorate it
with apples, with tangerines,
with nuts, with dried figs.
I remember as children we would
make sort of wreaths of bay leaf
and dry fig, a bay leaf, a dry fig,
a bay leaf all tied
not even with a string.
There is -- it was called
banka [assumed spelling].
It's a very pliable strong grass.
And we would tie it.
And the whole tree was decorated
with that rather than
tencel and so on.
So the story's about that.
And at the end I give recipes
so the many families can do this
with the children and build
this organic tree at home.
And ultimately those
were our presents.
We didn't have presents.
On La Befana or the 6th of
January the tree gets dismantled.
And those were our
gifts, and we ate them.
Although, I mean, my brother and
I, because we had put also candy,
caramelle, we would steal the candy
and put a stone in there or a rock
in there so that the tree looked
good, but we were munching
at it as it was going on.
The illustrations are great.
It's the illustration of all my
grandkids and myself and grandma.
So it's realistic.
And, also, there will
be a half hour special
on public television of the book.
So it's an exciting holiday
season coming up for our family,
because we do those things at home.
Now we can share that, also,
outside, maybe touch the children,
get the children involved.
Of course that's everybody's
concern these days.
So I'm going to open up.
We have about ten minutes
of questions.
And please.
Yes?
>> It's such a pleasure
to see you here.
It's great.
My mother is 89.
My family is Dutch
from the Netherlands.
She survived the hungry winters
in Holland during World War II.
One of the things that
sustained her, she had a book.
She doesn't remember
the author or the title.
It was an Italian family in New
York, and they were preparing
for a wedding and the
vast quantities of food.
And she would read that at that
time, which may be why my family,
once we were in America, were very
interested and ate Italian food.
As I said, she's 89.
I've learned all my
cooking from her.
She's a wonderful cook,
and she loves your show.
She loves when your
mother comes on board.
She just adores that
and the grandkids.
And she said to me this morning,
because I said I might get a chance
to speak to Lidia, she
sends you greetings.
And she said, if she still could
cook -- it's beyond her now --
she would be cooking from your book.
>> Wow, that's wonderful.
>> Thanks so much.
>> Much gratitude to her.
Give her my best.
>> I will do that.
>> Tell her grandma is
90 and still kicking.
She's bossing everybody in that
TV crew, telling them what to do.
So she's spiffy.
So wish her all my best and
much continued Italian cooking.
>> Thank you.
And as a child, I have
a very clear memory.
I can still hear my mother's rolling
pin going when she was doing pastry.
Do you have a special memory?
I know you must have many, but
is there something that stands
out when you were a child that
really clicked you into the food
that your family was cooking?
>> If you're talking about
sounds, you know, specifically now
that you're talking, I
remember a lot of smells.
You know, smell, we have a
large -- as primates, you know,
we sort of smell for our food.
We look for our food.
So we have a lot of space
reserved for our sense of smell.
And it collects a lot of memories.
So that's why when
you smell something,
it takes you right
back into that moment.
But the sound, you know, what
I remember, I remember sitting
with a little stool with the goat,
and I would help my
grandmother hold the legs
so the goat would stay still.
And the way she was milking and
the sound that the milk made
into the can and all
the froth that came
out of it and ultimately drank it.
So if you're talking about
sound, that's a sound that sort
of comes back to me now and then.
Thank you.
Yes?
>> You obviously researched
all the Italian regions.
And besides your own home region,
which region for you
has your favorite food
or a special ingredient or dish
that is one of your favorites?
>> Right. You know, it's like
saying, what's your favorite child.
I think I love them all, but I think
that they really change
within the season.
And some regions are much better
than others in certain regions.
So if you're talking about
now going into the Fall,
I would go up to Piemonte,
the Porcini, the truffles,
even Emilia Romagna, that hearty
pasta, a lot of Pachino sauce.
If you talk about summer, maybe just
like right now, Sicily,
the [inaudible].
The tomatoes are just wonderful.
So I think that, you know, I travel
maybe with the seasons through Italy
to find what I really
appreciate and enjoy.
Okay.
>> I've been to your
restaurant in Pittsburgh.
It was excellent.
I remember the lamb shank fondly.
So thank you so much.
>> Thank you very much.
Yes, sir?
>> Having arrived here at age
12, I'm sure there's been a lot
of trials and tribulations
and influences
that may have impacted
on where you are today.
Can you speak to that?
>> Yes. You know, I think that
maybe my drive -- I'm challenged.
I always loved to research, to find
new things, but the challenge maybe
that got me this passion,
this drive is maybe my story.
And I come from an area, now
it's Istria and now it's Croatia,
but it was part of Italy.
And after World War II that part
was given to then Yugoslavia,
the new country that
[inaudible] became Yugoslavia.
Yugoslavia was communist.
The iron curtain went up.
The part where we were remained
behind the iron curtain.
We could not speak Italian.
I mean, any boarder situation is
where people are mixed ethnicity.
I mean, I speak five languages
in the sense of, you know,
all the languages, but
at home we speak Italian.
So we couldn't speak Italian.
I couldn't go to church.
And all of these things
really weighed on my parents.
And ultimately in 1958 --
now, I was born in '47.
And this happened between
'47, '48, '49,
that whole division of that area.
And in about 1955, '56 we
were old enough as children,
my parents decided that they
wanted to go back to Italy.
Now, there was a period that ethnic
Italians, when it was divided,
could just -- it was
called the exodus.
And 350,000 Italians,
ethnic Italians
from that area went back to Italy.
My mother was pregnant with me.
So she stayed.
That was why.
So once in about 1955
they decided to go back.
My mother, my brother
and I went as tourists.
They wouldn't allow the whole
family to go back, because they knew
that they wouldn't come back.
My father literally escaped.
We went to Trieste.
In Trieste we had other family,
because the proximity there is
so close that you had
family all over.
We reunited with them.
It was difficult to find a job
in those situations, whatever.
And we were settled ultimately in a
refugee camp, political refugee camp
in Trieste called San Sabba
for two years while we awaited
an opportunity to migrate.
And ultimately it was
President Dwight Eisenhower,
because even immigration was
stopped in the United States,
that he opened a limited
immigration for political refugees.
And we were one of the first people.
We were a young family.
So I think coming here,
we were brought here
by the Catholic charities.
We didn't have anybody.
The catholic charities
found us a home
and ultimately fed
us in the beginning.
So we are a product and,
you know, we became --
at least I became resilient
in a sense.
I am very blessed, because now I
have two of the greatest cultures.
I came here at 12.
So I feel very American, as well,
but these two great cultures.
But the challenge was, I
think, to prove to my parents
that their decision -- because
they were very nostalgic,
and I remember my father especially,
he just couldn't, you know, get it.
Did he do the right thing,
bringing here these children
when they were not having anybody?
So I think we had to prove to them
that they did the right thing.
And it was my brother and I.
And my brother also
really succeeded.
He's an engineer in electronics,
and he has a few hundred
patents for IBM.
So I think that that drive
was really on both sides.
Not so much a personal
drive of gain,
but one of really showing our
parents that they were right.
And my mother now enjoys
and she's happy
and she's part of this success.
So I think that's a deep question.
[ Clapping ]
>> Hi, Lidia.
>> Hi.
>> I'm curious to know
how does one decide
to know what to cook for the Pope?
What kind of dinner conversation
do you have with the Holy Father?
>> That was really one of
the highlights of my career.
And the point is not
demanding at all.
He doesn't like cinnamon.
So that's it.
But it was also decided also
by his confidants, if you will.
The first immediately was a Friday.
And we had 55 cardinals from
all over the United States.
So Friday it was fish.
We did a whole roasted fish.
I did some soup, because I
felt that if he was traveling,
he needed some soup and all that.
And he ate a big plate of soup.
But, you know, he is German.
I come from that area as
I was just saying before,
you know, middle European.
I did some research.
His mother was a chef in Germany.
So he had a palate.
So I said, I wanted to come,
because, you know, here's a man,
it's not about him, it's
about everybody else.
And I don't think he considered --
I mean, in his position that he
considers so much his feelings
and his -- so I wanted
to give him pleasure,
maybe recollections again
when he was a child.
So I cooked sauerkraut.
I cooked goulash.
I cooked strudel.
And he loved it all
and he enjoyed it.
And I had the liberty to do that.
So at the end -- I don't know
if some of you saw the picture,
but at the end it was
also his birthday.
We brought him a cake.
And as I brought him the
cake, I gave him a knife
to cut it and he couldn't.
So I just took his hand
and we cut it together.
And I turned to him and I said,
"Your Holiness, how did you enjoy?"
And he looked at me and
he said, "delicious.
These flavors are my
mother's flavors."
So I have gotten into him.
[ Clapping ]
>> Hi. I would just like to thank
you for being on public television.
Growing up, I never had cable.
So I was always watching
you on Saturday afternoon.
And my question is, I see you
judging on Iron Chef America,
but would you ever compete on
it and who would you challenge?
>> You know, I don't think --
I refuse actually to compete.
It's not my style.
It's not what I do.
I don't have to prove anything.
And I am a judge, yes,
you know, objective judge.
I appreciate it.
I watch it, but it's not my style.
I think we are on overtime.
Maybe one more question.
>> Lidia, my wife -- hello.
Lidia, my wife and I enjoy
your cookbooks and the TV show.
>> Can you come closer?
>> We enjoy your cookbooks
and your TV show immensely.
I have a question for you.
>> Sure.
>> As I'm sure you know, Julia
Child's kitchen is located
in a museum not too far from here.
>> Yes.
>> Many years from now
would you be able to,
if asked, donate your kitchen?
>> Oh, my gosh, you're honoring
me with this projection here,
but I guess whatever
the future holds.
But I cooked in that kitchen.
I went to visit it.
I filmed in the kitchen
that's in the Smithsonian.
And I visited with Julia.
In her last days she
went to Santa Barbara,
because she was from Santa Barbara.
So I visited with her
in the last days.
She was a tremendous influence in
my career as far as the presence
on television and how she projected
and she cared about her viewers,
not about herself,
and she communicated.
And when I got up there and I
said, you know a lot of chefs are,
I can do this, I can do that,
and it's not about that.
It's about communicating.
And she was very instrumental.
And I looked at her and I
said, that's what I want to do.
Okay. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[clapping].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.